hi its III in like two weeks
this might be our last episode for a
while maybe I don't know when do you
leave the 11th right after Ubisoft okay
I came to LA I leave earlier I leave
next week on like Friday so if you can
record before then we can do it again
try but I mean if we can Wednesday or
something we'll see I'm sure people
nobody wants to watch this endo is
releasing well no any Claire conference
I'm sure people would want to watch this
and they would break it some beat their
weekend but yeah I don't know that the
powers that be at GameSpot would be able
to use that slot when it could be used
for Nintendo news or something like that
I'll figure it out this is the last
episode before e3 for a while cuz those
of you know the game know we're coming
up on a good chapter ending if that
makes sense
cool we'll see where we go but and I'm
gonna keep doing this format for the
rest of knievel just I know there's one
person that YouTube comments who keep
calls everybody morons he was a spot to
be equal to each other if you're being
mean we're happy here yeah we found a
happy place it's here okay remember what
you did last time you got that Valve
I got this machine room key and I got a
gas mask yeah you don't need a gas mask
yet and I got some advice from a youtube
commenter who told me that you can shaky
them bugs off so if the winged little
shits lay eggs in me apparently you can
just like freak out and she'll rip them
off of her own back and then she doesn't
get poisoned oh okay I haven't tested it
and I don't plan on it because I'm
roasting a bunch of buttons I don't use
the motion I don't know no not the
motion I just said like yeah pressing a
bunch of buttons yeah do you like this
okay well what do I need currently
because I have but I don't you won't
need this all rifle in fact again I
won't spoil anything but I'd put down
the item
assault rifle in the item box maybe just
equip your handgun okay I have my
handgun here maybe take a green urban
case but other than that you're good
we're not you're not going crazy far I
am on caution so it's something to
consider make it be fine and am I going
to the machine room yeah I don't
remember where it is I'm sure we'll
figure it out it's not the door you've
been going through in the moth room it's
back where you came from when you first
crashed into Empire oh [ __ ] so I'm going
straight yeah okay let's do it you ready
mm-hmm do it what are the odds no it
won't happen because I'm [ __ ] these oh
wait I went the wrong way I [ __ ] it up
by like with you I don't know this is a
good test look this up but I'm finding
this like do you think it requires the
shoulder buttons yeah that was different
nice shoulders it was just I just I just
threw a bunch of buttons I really if I
can find that user that was so cool I
think it also might have happened on
Twitter but you can look at the comments
- oh I remember seeing in the comments
and I remember the tweet and I really
appreciate that it just saved me can
evil I don't know what episode was last
episode 9 here we go what's this where
am I
yeah you're on the resurrection I think
should be a locked door somewhere up
here
oh these camera angles yeah terrible you
fought like four I do mama I started
with a Christmas story episode Christmas
story well last time apparently there's
a lot of stuff in here I missed when I
joined the umbrella Inc I thought that I
would be able to live carefree for the
rest of my day
because I was employed by a huge
corporation what an idiot
a corporation don't care about you and
when I say that I don't mean an umbrella
I mean any corporation Whole Foods is
corporate we own them what Amazon it
owns whole food Amazon I meant twitch
well I don't twitch Amazon just is an
umbrella that owns many evil
corporations it's a joke that I ended up
being a driver at a place like this I
asked for a position change but they
completely ignored me it feels more like
a prison work is extremely demanding and
there's nothing fun about it I'd rather
be dead next page I'm dead my hard
earned vacation they cancelled suddenly
I heard they failed to secure enough
manpower due to a mistake made by the
facility head Alfred that fool
Oh also one thing I want to do this
episode we got I don't know I made two
things keep keep going
actually now hold on I want to point out
Nathan Shepard on YouTube yeah he's the
one who regularly updates our stats yeah
[ __ ] I wish I knew how to do this better
welcome I'll figure it out I want to
show the the fan art we got to okay I
just took the HDMI out and I would think
I would put it in that PC or sorry in
the know I'll figure it out or I'll yeah
I might need to do that but we'll do at
the end of the episode okay all right I
heard an interesting story from a guy
who's been working here for eight years
he says that there's a man who's been
confined for over ten years locked up in
a Cell
they call him Nosferatu Nosferatu I woke
up to an ominous growling sound I'm so
pathetic I was frightened good thing
you're just the driver
I suppose anyone would have heard a hard
time maintaining their sanity if they
were confined in a place like this all
right so it's just a really unhappy
person undefined variable said I can't
speak for anyone else but I'm sure I can
watch this and III content I would love
to nice we can talk to
have to talk to the people who get paid
to make this decision also yeah
undefined variable said also no one
cares what's their caps a lot and his 13
of their accounts thing and then Ricardo
car back to you said some advice for
next episode
neither the moths nor the poison kill
you they just leave you permanently in
danger so I guess it doesn't it'll just
leave you poison well I remember what
happened was I got poisoned and then a
zombie killed me so that's why I'm
trying to avoid that all right well I'm
not disappointed that I went in here
because I found a lot of [ __ ] that I
missed but I don't see this door so I
don't think this is where I'm supposed
to be so I'm going to leave that's fine
because I got I got two rounds of
bullets and a really sad diary of
disgruntled employee ok so there's it
would be like going outside here that
maybe you might have been on Twitter
it was definitely on Twitter I remember
replying and being like think you think
you think you think you thank you but I
wasn't able to like utilize a ah I found
it
I will disregard discs I will disregard
this place looks
ominous
I almost just scared you as a joke and
then what is oh man it's a digging
vehicle if we break the wall with it we
might have a chance okay let's do it
there's someone better voice actors
buried under there
Steve music are you sure you don't want
to like go to sleep first so I can like
smell your hair poorly-designed vehicle
do not look at me your stupid boner just
got us killed
Steven is erection once again screwed us
again he's now is leaking lethal gas
it's all my fault yes it is
don't say that we'll escape from here
don't say that I have a juicy butt so
weird got to shut off the gas if we
split up we'll have a better chance of
stopping it okay I love you I love you
don't forget we'll get out of here
together
gross
wait what can you go back in there now I
think it's got gas in it you have a gas
mask remember I do but I don't have it
on me
oh [ __ ] a point wait on just do me try
it okay okay so I do have a gas not
straight go get it and just come back I
think okay is there a closer item box I
don't think so okay so I'm just going
back
[Music]
oh [ __ ] I gotta go back in the [ __ ]
bug world trying to gauge how long this
episode might be boss leave me alone
[ __ ] are they hurting me are they just
like tickling me
with their gross bug hands I want I'm
just gonna check ah [ __ ] like a poisoned
happen I don't know but I'm [ __ ]
gonna die
um can't you're gonna stay at poison I
think you bet poisonous will fine but I
pulled out the egg
all right let's start for some Juke edge
all right I'm on orange car shows I'm
not fine oh my god that bug is gonna eat
me yeah didn't don't do that he's run
but I hate them damn it do the do the
shake thing again will bit oh that might
have poisoned you I hate this it can't
kill you just keep going no no don't
poisoned it can't kill you you'll stay
at red or whatever you're not gonna I
don't like it you're gonna you're just
gonna get poison again like I'm on
danger you're better off either going
through don't use a healing item at this
point wise cuz you're better off either
wiping and restarting order nice he
threw stupid bugs so much you should be
able to kill everything in this ajikko
through that door yet
yeah yeah that's that that's where I
found the disgruntled employee diary go
is there a door to the right that's it
all right can you use that ladder this
no no that's a left there's a ladder
yeah
Oh oh my god I didn't know that was
there
I don't I'm doing super hot oh is this
where that okay I've been up here you
just want to investigate yeah
oh sorry okay well no now we know
where's the plane all right so we're
going in here I'm gonna put on my gas
mask I guess and we're gonna go inside
yeah I wonder if you can put it on now
or I don't know wait there's music is
there a zombie now wait no hold on go
back to the oh yeah you're here you
might as well try there
maybe have to use a at the door
again there should be like a valve
handle right like that's the last thing
that we haven't used yet I'm that room
with the valve hole
oh really thank you you are dead [ __ ]
look out [ __ ] yeah okay not I will
admit you should probably I should
definitely you know I just didn't I
don't think there's gonna be any fights
on the way to your next thing though but
if there's a zombie I'll die like if I
get hit once I'm dead okay
I had Billy Joel's stuck in my head all
day not his music mind you just him that
beard oh there we go sweet Oh what's the
what's the noise the valve thing makes
the beginning of game valve games
yeah but then isn't there like a weird
basic no I no real bells make that snow
it's on like the back of a dude's neck
it makes me uncomfortable
um where do I use this though you'll
remember once you see it so it's not in
here no no it's it's back I know what
you're talking about it's outside it's
in the up east air station near that
power switch that gave us so much grief
yeah so I have to go all the way back
right yeah okay um can you keep going to
the left of the door up here sure I
thought we did that oh did you
nope okay where am I don't know but
there's a dur aluminum case right there
duralumin sorry there's also a
disgruntled employee
it looks like he's caged in right now
have I never been in here before
oh they save ribbons
oh that's good I mean it's good to have
them I'll never complain about save
ribbons you'll never hear that from more
handgun ammo back there - in herbs is it
a machine what's that machine that looks
like one of those copy machines [ __ ] is
this the same thing that I did before it
might be in case you didn't do it
earlier that like wears like the handle
to like let them in there's two herbs on
the ground
oh wait actually what can you check well
you know pick this stuff up can you
check the valve yeah that's a square
yeah and the other one was enough can
you see if you need to observe it yeah
the hole was an octagon hexagon
okay so that's not the right one them or
you can use it on the medal machine the
metal machine on it is what I'm
wondering oh okay I see I see
nice nice I see what you're saying let's
go oh yeah I just cut off the corner
just makes it into a dick I didn't know
what I wanted I mean I appreciate it
sorry well I would have been knowing if
we went all the way who did go no you
got two handgun packs right yes how do I
open that door I'm trying no no like
just just click on the actual door now
yeah no feedback I was thinking it was
like this lever cuz I'd like to get in
there
what should I do it doesn't even give me
a comment or anything I don't think you
can get it right now like he's obviously
upset I would - he's just locked in
there they never let me take my vacation
I want my 30 minute lunch break vacation
sick days don't care no air
look at that bunch of dudes down there
Hulan together have a little dance the
four of them there's only one coming for
the bottom I having a good time okay
downstairs to the left I hate this
goddamn area so [ __ ] much where you
can stop at the safe box to drop some
stuff off collect anything right damn
you
I hate those goddamn bugs wait was it
always like this
nope oh this is the room we just saw
thank you nope no I mean you already
started on this dude um am I going up
those stairs though eh I go the wrong
way I honestly don't remember yes I
think so because the other one is the
spider room packed back there
you just get picked up geese amount of
handgun around you should be good
killing these dudes I'd rather you spend
those than health right now I know I
really don't have a lot of health
now your point goddamnit
do not use that blower why cuz you have
unlimited supply right out in the
hallway just dude I'm going to die marry
for maybe the fourth time this episode
is literally at fourth you cannot die
from being poisoned it'll just keep you
at red I don't like it
show your stupid self if you want you
can go on poison yourself right now if
you want the box you're not gonna go
into the box right okay let me kill
these idiots I actually can't go
investigate it because I cannot like get
hit show yourself
I knew that was gonna happen
Thanks okay
oh man I am not looking so hot
so I'm gonna go get some herbs the
butterflies can they kill me yeah but
you're not gonna run into them right
here you're just gonna let me look
they're so annoying [ __ ] they suck so
much they've been the bane of my
existence
okay so I think it's up here yeah oh
yeah there was a spider in here right
now that's a could be just hobbling my
weak ass up here it is
it's where Steve put it before Dumbo
jumbo almost got us killed I'm not like
an expert on gas or anything but would
you really would they make a fail-safe
metal-on-metal potentially blowing
everybody up I just know so little about
poison
[Music]
oh my god that's not a good way to use
guns but she's alive
did they both think about it wait no the
rifles blowing let that dude at the
bottom of that vent oh it might have
been Nosferatu the guy who makes the
noises when I go into the yeah it's
creepy does he have a little bottle cap
on his ear a little brain on his back
well shackles on his arms
is this um
[Music]
this isn't gonna be like a thing is it
this isn't gonna be like a boss fight
thinking like res III where I like oh no
dude you know don't talk to Steve yet
okay this is the point where we go back
and do items and save because you're
pretty much Oh am I in a point of no
return
yeah there's there's a thing you do in
this room that triggers the rest of got
it yeah okay so I'm gonna go do what
then I'm gonna leave you might want to
use that green herb anyway because I
don't think you're gonna be able to
dodge the bugs without healing you
definitely think the bugs will kill me
can the bugs kill me yeah but yeah they
can hurt you I think but like also like
you're not gonna be able to dodge them
by limping through oh right she's like
tragic as much as possible
I think he's dead
okay Studebaker Miss Richard Nixon
Marilyn Monroe you like does the pixie
dust poison me yeah I mean it hurts you
I don't know if that poisons you I think
they needs actually you should probably
just save first cuz you gotta get rid of
the increments after anyway okay um yeah
let's save now I'm on I've gone through
an entire cycle of saves now that's
crazy six hours ready before this
weekend why you just wanted to that's
cool
I've only played it once on ps4 I played
through New Game+ alright yeah you don't
need to save ribbons I would get rid of
I feel like I could use a goddamn heal
but that's just me okay so get rid of
the bow gun and the arrows okay okay so
keep mind you're about to pick up the
rifle right I think I could use honestly
a first goddamn heal I would bring two
green herbs I don't know if I have you
know that's a blue oh yeah bring the
blue and then bring two okay
so again I don't wanna spoil anything
but there's more I'm trying to figure
how to say this without try to trust me
when I tell you to bring so this should
be good I think yes you have 60 hang
around you're fine
yes and you just saved we might not
succeed this time but there will be
you're saying not to bring anything else
yeah oh wait no you're you're I forgot
you're on yellow you can heal pretty you
could use a green herb or something well
I was thinking about or wait til you get
past me waiting to get past these
douches
am I going straight now you're going
back to where you came from take it the
rifle and talk to Steve was that that
way the past amounts to the blue or
can't Winter Games confidence [ __ ] you
wait what are you worried I'm poisoned I
mean yeah well now you can just die
anyway I don't think you got poisoned I
didn't think that anytime but I'm always
getting how like how there were no eggs
in this situation just dust sorry this
whole area sucks okay my unread mute
Robbie's agreed one of the green
she's a greener
or may I could just use the first aid
from orange because this isn't even
gonna get me yeah so to green I think it
would get me to yellow maybe what do you
think I can wait he's first aid we just
saved it anyway we got options all right
where am I going up those stairs
oh right I'm gonna go talk to Steve I
try to get the rifle first I forgot
which frat either talking to Steve worth
of getting the rifle trigger something
again this might even be this might be
the trigger yeah there's only seven
bullets on it says the guy who [ __ ]
gassed everyone yeah you [ __ ] this up
I'm gonna Buster are you ready
Oh interesting
right cha
Claire maybe she just came through there
we should have brought our winter vests
come on let's go
yeah they must be cold it looks like a
ladder or something
she's like a crop vest to like they're
not even full vests here
Claire come on get out of this insane
place
or anything up here should be aware over
yeah
Oh items
if there's always a helipad for
resonable games
I'll wait actually while you're here
nice while you're here can you I want to
show you how to hang in with this night
right I know oh [ __ ]
can you zoom in or out what are you
holding to aim the same as normal hold
press l1 when you're evaluating okay my
game and then press l1 okay yeah that's
that zooms how do ways oh it
automatically zooms out you have to hold
it to zoom in okay just so you know
that's pretty much it um actually for
other people who don't understand how
guns work where does the bullet go I'm
assuming right in the middle of the W
like am I gonna hit that square yeah
okay thanks just a very practical
reticle I don't play did you poop
yourself
Ronni
oh it does Oh what should I be shooting
at his head or is like arms or like his
butt well he's gonna go Steve
probably that beating heart in his chest
I didn't mean that sarcastically I'm
pretty sure that's okay that makes sense
he does have any urine I'll come back
just hang on for an hour or so in the
freezing cold when your finger is hurt
yeah wonder how long you catch like a
band or smooch
I can't see oh I like this I like the
way out it's creepy
I feel uncomfortable yeah let me closer
this is me and I can't see him you will
when he gets past the fog he's right
there I don't see it Arius oh wow that's
not good wait he sprayed me yeah you're
gonna have to be semi-closed - what
about that there you go yeah good I'm
actually
you're fine you're gonna shoot it nice
yeah just keep doing that
[Music]
[ __ ] [ __ ] that might have poisoned you
but you have a blower okay nope you're
good I'm pretty sure that can poison you
that makes sense let me know if you know
I thought do you see it
yeah you mock you what do I do about
that I have to get a little closer just
like so he doesn't keep spraying you
he's just got so much like gasps he's
right now yeah oh [ __ ] I missed I
panicked sorry
he's got a lot of arms to be honest with
you he's a really [ __ ] gross dude
yeah I mean you're like you're hurting
yourself by staying too far away because
you can't keep spraying you I got it so
you're saying I okay got it
you guys know just attack
oh god he sucks jet show me your gross
belly oh there it is oh all right
oh yeah a lot of okay I'm poisoned
combined blue green can been convinced
convinced yes
oh no I mean you're still technically
fine as long as you beat him
oh why that didn't what's the blue herb
do them
maybe you works cuz you were so poison
[ __ ] [ __ ] wood away - I think I'm out of
I just do handgun is it fully loaded pay
attention to your limits obviously if
you go okay I gotta go into the fog here
unfortunately yeah just get up oh my god
[Laughter]
well okay now that we know how to fight
him you save right before we can just
skip the gun okay so that's another
reason not to keep going too far from
him because he it wasn't wasn't that
poison he just pushed me off yeah that
was funny
I thought I got him oh that's not good
why not well that means that I can't
change my loadout you don't need to
change your loadout you're fine and also
you've saved worse case scenario turn
the PlayStation off and but you won't
need to just don't just don't let it
boys yeah but you know I know you're I
get why your instinct is to stay far
away from him wait for meeeeee to come
to you but like you're better off moving
you say that but when I changed and did
a different tactic I got pushed off the
ledge well cuz you let him walk to the
edge
the times you shot him or when he was
turning around to face you doing she
shot him when he turned around otherwise
you're letting him set up the pool
I don't think I always shot him in the
chest either so I'll do that more this
Tyler yeah I don't miss oh pretty far
again today not yet
you trying to prove point yes that's
good
there you go see good shot there you go
you got it just keep doing that when he
gets staggered no let him get come back
and shoot him you know you didn't need
to move oh when you staggered him and
then he was readjusting to shoot at you
oh [ __ ] I still got here good no but I'm
getting super poisoned
I know you saw her yelling at himself
don't mess him up let's find out how
poisoned I am but also like another
reason for him not to come toward you is
you run the risk of him getting close
enough to push oh you all he did it
behind the back that come on no you
could do that I didn't either that was
good
I'm impressed by him
[ __ ] huh run
there you go show me your chest you dick
hole she'll be your bosom oh [ __ ] I'm
out okay let's think about this [ __ ] oh
[ __ ] I'm poisoned alright so just use
the blue or by itself okay huh why
whatever cuz of resident evil that's
dumb
Oh Bert hey go [ __ ] him up oh look
that's all it took on the ground bones
more like Nosferatu dead only Steve had
fallen during this whole thing
push yourself that was he not frozen and
off look at him
do I look okay you're stupid it'll be so
good if she like grabbed him by his
three buckle bracelet but then they
started buckling one at a time where she
grabbed him by his fingers and they were
so frozen he's snapped Claire just left
arm curls him up of course the sister of
Chris Redfield can do that
I guess this is where we make out huh
[Laughter]
[Music]
probably sick killed you saving you
you are so friendzone I swear I'll
protect you next time Claire oh [ __ ] off
me you know oh look like a dream or
something
we beat the game look kind of his hurt
oh [ __ ]
this is like the beginning of national
treasure
a gem of a movie a gem of a movie if
ever there was one oh forget it felt
beasts Claire how the [ __ ] is this
person alive they were shot so many
times
[Music]
alexia
[Music]
alexia
[Music]
what was that oh what's that
what
[Music]
Wow they found a way make this so creep
[Music]
what do you think is gonna happen next
quick she's gonna eat him no I'm playing
his crits way better than what I thought
I thought she was gonna eat her brother
check out those [ __ ] biceps yeah you
said a band man
[Music]
oh great my home
I lost my kombucha my hostess dream and
my extra pair of socks badass intro that
was badass intro well I live here now
luckily I didn't expect to find another
living person left on this island who
are you so the guy gave the hemostat to
a girl have you seen anyone named Claire
Redfield have I seen someone named did
you ever see Claire you know who she is
don't you don't worry about her
she's killing helped her escape several
planes took off from this island not
long ago well I can't say for certain
she was probably on one of them I see
I guess my sister Rosie
thanks for helping
everyone's gone
and maybe the only other person left go
on
although your sister and get off this
island he's just his job on this entire
game is to tell people to leave him
behind there's like a sequel to this
game and he's like save yo odo
[Music]
okay bye oh no I have to go the bathroom
that was wondering why they brought that
sad guy back again and it was like oh oh
yeah you're gonna save him yeah I got it
Delic dedicate a light on my right hand
it seems that I can put the stone lid
down put the stone lid down so if I can
get a lighter I can fix this
don't have a lighter I do not have a
letter I thought maybe little revolves
yeah open up the item box quick okay let
me get these uh yeah I thought that
wasn't increment is this shared yeah
it's all clear stuff oh my god I've been
robbed that's why I was I suggested I
take as little as possible okay see
because you just get it for him yeah and
also we can get the magnimous Chris
later wow that's really misleading
because you would think you would want
everything you could to beat that guy
but not bringing anything makes the game
easier later his game is mean it's also
yeah it's not good game design I mean
it's a cool concept saving stuff for the
second playthrough which you could do
that in certain spots and was able to
with a Leon and am i saving Claire
Claire Claire
he offers yeah that honestly might be a
good place to end it for now okay it's a
pretty good cliffhanger yes yeah it's a
good I don't know if we played an hour
though no but we can always record and
hold it you know sweet sweet what do you
think of this format for the game it's
really interesting cuz I've changed
people from spoiling the game for myself
wait what you think yeah okay so now we
know what's happening next what to
prepare for I could kill him with a gun
yeah but you don't want to I'd suggest
you yes you think I could kill him with
my name
you could try try to Knight them okay if
you can kill him with your knife uh-huh
I will do I'll do something crazy
I think I got don't shut my own for one
it's just not something that I would bet
you for it [ __ ] I almost got him give me
one second
so Rodrigo's inside him and you're
supposed to save him that's the rocks
falling from the ceiling a thing
I'm getting pretty hurt here the
stalactites
hard did like a Dark Souls boss
everything's like Dark Souls
oh forget it yeah
oh I got him on that one I saw purple
[ __ ] come out of him yeah
[ __ ]
I heard a my orange I'd say red [ __ ]
you're gonna get in this stomach be like
hey Rodrigo
[ __ ] its those rocks its the rocks I'm
dead all right
sorry a valiant effort what do I think
what do I think it's really good so far
I've actually liked that we've had three
totally different scene changes
wait Oh like island Antarctica you're
technically back on the first island but
I guess but I'm a different person so it
feels quite different I think unless I
end up just being in the same like if
I'm going to go to the mansion and be in
the mansion I guess that changes it
you'll retread some if you can get the
fire extinguisher then that's a hint
that you'll retract interesting
interesting yeah I think it's a it's a
really cool concept I can definitely see
where it doesn't age as well like the
idea of like punishing people by not by
sharing items like that and not letting
us have them like I think without you as
my guide I'd be pretty disappointed in
the fact that I would have lost it's
just a couple yeah but it's fun and
they've done a really good job but kind
of keeping it scary
I hate those [ __ ] bugs it's probably
good good stuff thanks for joining
everybody yeah we will do our best to
get an episode up yeah it's not us it's
more an e3 issue and you guys are
definitely gonna want all that III
madness right at your doorstep and
there's always so many things that
happen that the YouTube channels just
like swarmed with trailers and stuff and
everything just gets buried you know and
it's it's not always the best time to
release long-form content like this so I
think it might be best to hold it but
we'll see maybe we can get it out like
early like what if we released it Friday
or something before e3 it's like a
possibility or something
but in the meantime enjoy the rest of
your weekend and thanks for joining us
yeah see you later
Hey except for you three I was so afraid
you would actually for LA that worm I I
stabbed him